hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
thank you so much for coming to my
channel i'm a property investor
recently you may have seen me posting
videos of castles and
financial freedom challenges doing lots
of deals making lots of money and also
my students doing the same thing too
so i decided right now on this sunday
evening to
answer any questions that you have got
about property investment
right now right here on q a sunday so
please do me a massive favor
smash the like button also subscribe so
you don't miss a video
so last week we had a bunch of questions
so here's how this is going to go
i'm going to start answering questions
in the youtube
comments right now what i want you to do
is i want you to
ask me anything at all in this video
so go to the comment box and just ask
any question that you've got about
property and then i'll do my very best
to answer your question next week so
let's see what happened last week so
we've got a guy called daz
g he said as you know the rules about
property are slightly different in
scotland
and i think that puts doubt in viewers
from the region would you consider doing
one of your from
scratch challenges in scotland and show
us all how the pros
do it thanks a lot your content is great
all right um so a few things i'll say
about scotland and just generally with
the challenges
would i go and do a financial freedom
challenge in scotland uh yeah heck yeah
i would actually i'd love to do it i
just did one in ireland
in fact that's coming out the full
island um
challenge is going to be coming out in
two days time it's going to be coming on
tuesday evening
so make sure you don't miss that all
right so make sure you're subscribed
it's coming out on tuesday evening
where i went to ireland with no money
and helped a guy
who also had no money become financially
free it took us seven days
you'll see exactly what happened on
tuesday um in scotland
i mean listen everywhere i go i've done
financial freedom challenges in america
i've done them in different parts of the
uk just outside the uk
um in ireland and i what i've found is
the rules are slightly different but the
strategies work the same so scotland
the only major difference in scotland is
that when you put an offer on a property
and it's accepted
you have to buy it that's basically it
it's very very similar i would kill it
in scotland but right now
i have no intentions to do another
financial freedom challenge right this
moment because i've just done one
my wife has just had a baby and i'm just
going to enjoy being at my house
for a bit in buckinghamshire so i hope
that helps go
kill it in scotland daz you can do it
fabio
when sending letters to hmo landlords if
the address
of the owner is not on the register how
would you go about
finding it if the address of the owner
is not on the register
you don't need to you don't need to find
the address if you're trying to if
you're trying to find a hmo landlord
you don't need to you can just go on
spare room
code at uk and then rather than finding
the landlord's address and sending a
letter
just text the landlord just text them on
spare room
or just pick up the phone and phone a
hmo management company and say
hey could you put me in any of your hmo
landlords or be interested in my service
this is what my service is
boom 2021
i mean letters are really good but you
don't need letters but you can find the
addresses of the owner
they normally if you if you just type in
hmo
register in such and such an area
you'll probably get the whole list from
the council and if you don't
you can ring up the council and you can
request that they give you every single
address of the
every licensed hmo in that area and
they'll give you that
that i mean we're not short of
information what we're short of is
people taking
massive action so fabio go kick some ass
um syed says what are the fees for rent
to rent
there are no fees for doing rent to rent
just do a rent if you've got a company
rent to rent is a service that you're
offering
if you want to charge a fee you can but
you're saying to a landlord
i mean normally you're going to need to
pay the landlord is going to expect
one month's upfront rent and they're
going to expect maybe a deposit
okay great so i mean i just did a rent
to rent in ireland with david
it was actually this was in derry so
just on the norther
um in north island uh northern ireland
um
and we just paid 1 300 pounds
one month's rent one month's deposit
secured a rental rent
michael says love the content i can't
wait to start my property
uh next year when i'm 18 years old my
question is how long
do you get typically to pay back your
refinance
loan um i'm not 100 sure if i understand
the question if you if
you get a loan you know if you refinance
a property and you've got a loan
how when how long before you pay it back
never pay it back
ever you're 18 years old almost
you want it forever
so you know the i this idea that we get
a
mortgage and we pay it back and we have
to save up to pay off the mortgage
quickly
is financially [ __ ]
unless you're buying a property to live
in
then you don't want a debt because
at some point that that that debt is
gonna have to be paid off
but if you're buying a property as an
investment that debt never has to be
paid off because
the tenants are just gonna keep on
paying the interest and on top of that
paying you
your income and the house is gonna
over time probably continue appreciating
that debt is
good debt that's serving you you don't
want to pay it off
i probably would suggest that you don't
pay off your own mortgage either i'd
probably suggest you don't get a
mortgage on your own house i'd suggest
that you just rent it
rent where you live and rent out what
you own
get good debt on what you own because
the debt
will need to be paid interest will need
to be paid sorry but that's being paid
by the tenants
people too many people went to school
and listened to what their school
teachers told them and listened to what
their
parents told them whose parents parents
told them that
which is old-school victorian mindset
around money
which keeps the vast majority of people
poor you want to know why people are
poor
across the world in the uk people are
not poor because of lack of money
people are poor because of lack of
knowledge in how to make
manage and preserve money and wealth
okay paul says i was inspired by your
last financial freedom challenge i want
to get my foot in the door i wanted to
start finding and selling deals my
question
is is there a way to find investors
without a network of contacts
you need to get a network of contacts is
there a way to find
investors without a network of contacts
well the way to
get a network of contacts is to find
investors so the two go hand in hand
that's not saying is there a way to find
investors without having investors
yeah there is you need to get inside one
of those network of contacts
you need to join communities like my
facebook group which is
free 30 000
members free to join
and to talk and to discuss and to bring
value
and to let the world know who you are
it's free everything is free
investors networks free
knowledge information it's all free
it's available partly because of me
doing stuff like this
and my groups and my youtube videos
people saying how do i find out
where the hmos are it's free you go to
the council and you
ask for it and they give it you for free
doesn't we're not sure of money and
we're not sure
of information and we're not sure of
good evil oh i've got this really good
idea samuel i don't
need a good idea too many good ideas
there's too few good people that will
actually facilitate
and implement and take action on those
good ideas
there's too much fear everyone's
everyone's scared everyone's a [ __ ] in
2021.
everyone says everyone's afraid they're
afraid of losing
but you can't win unless you're prepared
to lose
they're afraid to fail but you can't
fail unless
you have to fail your way to success
when i do my financial freedom
challenges do you think that it's all
success
it's not all success the dude behind the
camera
path who's filming me right now he films
my financial freedom challenges and pav
is it all success
it's a lot of failure but but but
you cannot have success without failure
you can't it's like if you if you're
playing a game of football
you keep kicking the ball i mean i mean
you only get one or two goals in a game
everyone remembers the goals what they
don't remember is all the times you
missed
and it's the same it's the same in life
everyone sees my successes
but what they well they don't see is my
failures
the times i'm rejected which which
happens a lot and it has to
so that's what you need to start doing
taking action
creating your prosperity says hi samuel
hope you're well for
four bed unlicensed hmos what legal
requirements do i need to comply with to
make this
happen and also is it a legal
requirement to have communal areas in
licensed and unlicensed hmos
okay so first things first a licensed
hmo and an unlicensed hmos i personally
run them
pretty much the same a licensed hmo just
means that because it's of a certain
size usually five bedrooms or more
because it's of a certain size and
there's a certain amount of people in
that property
the council say you need to show you're
responsible so you need to have a
license
namely the property needs to be fit for
purpose
and you can't be a criminal that's
basically what they check
when i've got a three bed or a four bed
hmo even if it doesn't need a license
i'm still going to run the property to
the standard whereby i would
pass a license should i need a license
even though i don't
why because i want my properties to be
good i want to be a good landlord i want
to have a good product
property investing is a business your
house is your product
and your tenant is your customer so i'll
i'll run it as if it's licensed
so to answer you but if it's if it's not
licensed no one will check it
the council won't come and look at it
because it's not licensed so you can run
it
you know kind of how you want within
reason unless you're breaking
other laws um but how i run it and how i
would advise all my students to run it
as if it's licensed
so to answer your question about
communal areas do you need to have
communal areas
the rules are every bedroom if it's
licensed
every bedroom needs to be 70 square feet
of 6.5 square meters that's about the
size of a small room you get a single
bed a wardrobe
small room okay no box room small room
70 square feet
that's the minimum requirement for rooms
now if the rooms
are all large double rooms namely 100
square feet
you do not need a communal area for
licensed hmos so you've got five rooms
they're all 100 square feet 100 square
feet is double bedroom
chester drawers wardrobe nice bit of
floor space good size decent healthy
room not massive but just a good size
decent room
if they're all like that you don't need
a communal area at all
you can turn the communal area into
another bedroom
if they're smaller than 100 square feet
then you should have a communal area
so that that that's the rules all right
kieran wilson
uh hi samuel kind of started like
yourself bought two properties outright
in my own name
would it be more beneficial in future to
buy properties through a limited company
or will it differ from person to person
um okay great question kieran so there
are tax advantages to buying through
a limited company hands down if you've
already bought properties in your
individual name
it's probably not worth switching over i
haven't switched over
because you've got to pay stamp duty and
it's just it's not worth the hassle
the cost to switch your properties from
individual name
to a company however moving forward it
probably
is best to buy through a company now i
am not a
tax advisor neither do i know your
situation
but my advice to you my guidance would
be that you
speak to a tax advisor you give them
your situation and then you decide
what's best
but probably a company would be a good
option because
you can claim things back as tax
deductible
such as your mortgage expenses your
mortgage payments you can't claim that
back if
you own it individually which is a pain
so
more tax efficient there are
disadvantages as well to only get
in a company but there are more
advantages to disadvantage
usually speaking so go speak to a tax
advisor keep up the good work
meet george do you invest in anything
else besides property
stocks etc um look man properties might
think
i love property i know property i love
the fact that everyone has to live
somewhere
there's so many reasons why i love
property investment and why i think it's
by far
superior to most investments do i invest
in other stuff a little bit
you know i'm i'm in business obviously
i just invested in a few businesses last
week actually
some really good stuff one of my
students on um but anyways another story
um cryptocurrencies is something that i
am being
um introduced to i mean you can't ignore
it
you can't ignore it i've got a little
bit of bitcoin but
the thing is i can have bitcoin and i
can hope that it's going to go up in
value but it's not going to pay me any
rent
so i like property the most but but
i'm not an expert in other investments
maybe i'm an expert in business possibly
um
but property i think is a safe bet and
property is going to be around for
hundreds and hundreds of years
so it's something that i can pass down
to my kids and my kids kids
um but yeah i mean i'm very very pro
other investments my favorite is
property hope that helps
okay um thanks for leading the way in
helping us improve their lives
through property your start you're
welcome after four years renting
my wife and i decided to buy a forever
house for us to
the kids we complete in a few weeks and
are putting an extension
on the house and upgrading throughout we
have a small property management company
so my question is
after adding significant value could we
refinance the house to our property
company
and if so could we rent it to ourselves
through
our company um
okay so a couple things firstly i don't
think you're going to be able to
refinance it through your
property company if your property
company doesn't own
it okay now listen speak to your broker
and stuff by all means but that's my
understanding
also if you're pushing the value up and
then you're trying to refinance the
house
just be mindful that if it's your house
that you live in
it's not about the value of the house
it's about what you can afford
more than anything if you live in a
house
and you're trying to get finance on that
house
the banks know that that house
it's just a personal loan basically they
might have collateral on the house fine
so they will want to value the house
but they're not going to want to give
you money unless they know that you can
pay that money back
you can pay the interest and how are you
going to do that
if it's an investment property they're
going to say well let's look at the
rentability
but if it's your property what they're
going to look at is your income
so you know i would definitely before
you start spending lots of money on
doing works and stuff
and and assuming that you can then
refinance i would get
mortgage advice um from a broker
and and go through that now i would
suggest that so i hope that's given you
a couple things to think about
and good luck okay last question
big boss 619 if there was a
house market crash by the way there will
be
people what do you mean well there's a
market
typically every 10 12 years there's a
market crash
because houses go up and then they go
down and then they go up and then they
go down it's no
big deal everyone's like oh my gosh it's
a big it's no big deal
but anyway if there was a market crash
which there will be will it impact
people who are on interest only mortgage
and how they pay their mortgage and
interest
um a crash will
impact everybody i guess to a degree
but not really no i mean i went when i
bought my first house in 2009
and then it dropped in value i've been
in negative equity with
with properties but it doesn't matter
unless you're planning on selling it
like let's say you buy a house for 100
grand and you're happy with it
you're buying the house for 100 grand
why are you buying the house you're
buying the house because you want an
income from it
so you buy 400 and you rent it outside
as a hmo and you're making
800 pound profit a month great good for
you you're renting it out you're making
800
a month are you planning on selling that
house no
what are you planning on doing just
keeping it and making your 800 pound a
month
because that's what you're living on
that's your passive income
do you want the house to go up in value
probably because then you can you can
get more equity you can you can release
more equity by refinancing it and then
you can use that money tax-free
to go buy more houses so yeah you
probably want to go up in value maybe
you don't want it to go up in value
because maybe you want to buy more
houses if you buy it for 100 and it
drops to 80
everyone oh my gosh you bought it for
100 it dropped to 80.
good because i bought it for 100 and
it's making me
800 a month now it's dropped to 80 which
means i can go and buy others in the
street now for even cheaper and get an
even better return on investment
good i'm glad it dropped if it goes up
good
i'm glad it went up truth is it doesn't
matter i don't care if the market's
going
down the market's going up what i care
about is my
income my passive income and in a market
crash
when properties are going down and
crashing usually rents go up
often happens why because people can't
afford to buy because there's a
recession going on
and often the house market crashes
because of a recession
often not always but during recessions
like we had a bad recession 2020 and
what happened to rents
they went up by about seven percent
across the uk
so there's no hard and fast rules but
generally speaking when you buy a
property you want to buy
one for cash flow for rent one for
capital appreciation sure but capital
appreciation doesn't pay the bills but
number three is you're gonna buy it
below market value anyway
so when you buy a property for 100 grand
you probably bought it it was probably
worth 125
if you're smart if it drops to 100 who
cares
then go and buy another one for 80. like
you need to make sure that when you're
buying you're sophisticated investor you
know what you're doing
you get the right training i say
everything's free
but samuel do you have expensive courses
i have a property investors crash course
guess what it's free join me at the
crash course
i'll leave a link in the description
come down on the house for free
uh that's going to be on the 7th of
april the next one um so get booked on
it's going to be absolutely incredible
where you can learn everything i know
about property condensed into
one day training program for free uh
also
if you've got questions about property
comment them below and i'll do my best
to answer
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
you can subscribe right here i'd love
you to subscribe
stop thinking and stop messing around
just subscribe to the channel do that
right now
and if you want to watch some more
exciting videos check them out right
here
and don't forget to subscribe as well
for david's channel david's ff challenge
is coming soon
i'll see you at the crash course peace
out thanks for watching
[Music]
you